yeah welcome to this video playing
vampire from Greece to 316 rated and I
went for default yeah only played him an
hour ago was something like that in a
pond siani where he was completely lost
who played the lost line but I forgot
the refutation again this age foreign
line which recently was what was called
a crap line by some guy commentating on
my videos yeah maybe it is a crap line I
don't know but it's played by many a
good players at the moment so it's um at
least leading to completely unexplored
possibilities okay so let's think about
that so I got the H file already but of
course he initiated some serious play in
the center what is it what I'd like to
do it I'd like to get the Queen to h4
trying to it to mate on age seven but
this is really very young very capable
like chess yeah but after all you played
h4 so okay maybe it maybe like that
Queen D for h1 as a possible idea but
384 I always need to take into account
that there is some Knight e4 hmm what a
strange in a strange position yeah this
was my idea
Queen a form take it then Queen h4 maybe
six I can play 95 for me
yeah complicated
yes I really don't think that h4s is so
terrible I mean it's leading to really a
completely unexplored play and I think
this this in itself has got some merit
so you you get new new positions and new
ideas okay so he's nicely developed of
course and all this didn't exactly help
my development six I can take it maybe
you should take it and the possible King
g7
what a strange opening yeah this is not
my typical style of play but it's it's
interesting to to get this kind of
complicated and hard to assess positions
I think you should really just take it
maybe he's got something better I don't
I don't know but he can take it and play
em can play King g7 at least yeah maybe
he's going to do that yeah and now this
one after Knight c5 I have before and
Queen c5 yup okay but this isn't a
really refutation of my my play if I go
green f4 even Queen a form twin h6 it is
a threaten why not
yes but I can take now and play 95 all
night 85 it's both interesting or first
check of course
all our castles you have many many
possibilities here maybe no castles at
one point I need to look hey this is
this is really a this is quick I mean
just push the e pawn and I'm ready to
take a six and playbook h1 check so this
is this is a quick a quick idea yeah of
course I'm also at the moment
threatening Queen check so he be
prevented there so the Queen she can't
talk yet if I go broke
d8 here do I prevent to prevent the
burmese maybe
I'll just default before getting getting
developed yeah at the end I'm a
classical player that gets let's get
stuff out if I F
yeah I wonder what night before maybe
night before it's good intending not a
true yeah it's possible and queen f2 is
also connected with the checkmate threat
yeah this is back how annoying is that
that it actually made threat I don't
mind so much
this capturing threat but Queen f2 is
really a problem what this isn't even
working
I'd be shiny five
I didn't didn't pay attention to that ah
what the heck
what a game again
check
check check check
check
yeah unfortunately he's the one with the
attack know what the nonsense time
working yeah again this guy has has
somehow wriggled its way out of this
position yeah I can just play up to
eight I guess
now I do not understand anything of this
why not just Rock the a they resign I
don't know
yeah probably this is also winning here
okay my for help
they have no mu fraud I don't have any
move ah what the heck I really think
maybe I'm too optimistic the computer
says blacks winning after night before
still I cannot believe in Bishop g4 but
then it's working we should have five
yeah I was far too optimistic him I
thought that this looked promising
really it seems that I need to play you
three player anymore
in a more restrained fashion I mean I
don't have any problems I can always
play a move like that and I'm okay but
or whatever III thought I'd look
promising to me maybe here maybe long
castles is really bad yeah it is
probably bad I need to go if for most
likely yeah long castles its France Rupp
d8 but it failed Stu yeah it doesn't
protect f2 and it runs into night before
so I probably need to play something
like that first yes yeah this is much
better
yeah this is much much better just
compare what what is black supposed to
play now after long casters he played
King g7 games u 7s it's a useful move
anyway but now I have for example I can
take play something like that
and ok it's not the end of the world for
blanket but it's it's it's a normal
position after long castle I I just know
castles I was just worse I could also
try that one
trying to pin him here and force the
Queen trade yeah this is probably around
equal but I was far too optimistic he I
really thought that long castles would
put him in danger now he assessed this
correctly I mean that before and so on
it was good was simply good alright
thanks for watching